rathe is the roarin fighter of apex
legends not much is really known about
her other than the fact that years ago
she woke up in an IMC detention facility
for the mentally ill with no memory of
her life beforehand she also began
hearing a distant voice whispering in
her mind it that would keep her awake
for days almost nearly driving her
insane but once she started listening
and trusting that voice it helped her
harness her newfound power
avoid manipulation and she used it to
escape the facility determined to
uncover her true identity rates began a
quest to find out about more about these
experiments and many of the old research
facilities however are sadly buried
beneath the heavily guarded arenas used
for apex legends so we'll see where she
goes from there hey guys welcome back to
a brand new video we're back on apex
legends again and we have another lore
video answering the question what
exactly is wraiths and how did she get
here and I will be explaining that
throughout the whole video and as always
before there isn't a lot of lore with
apex legends so I did have to go back
into titanfall 1 & 2 since they both
coexist within the same universe but as
always most of these videos are pretty
much speculation especially with rate
since we don't even know her name her
age or her homeworld so take this with
as much as you can with a grain of salt
but let me know your theories in the
comments below if you have a better one
than mine or you have something that
might be answering this exact question
but with that my Twitter and discord
will be in the description if you guys
want to hang out there and with that
let's get started so as I said before
her name homeworld and age are unknown
or as the biography says redacted but
there is a nobility in titanfall 2 very
similar to hers which is the phase shift
and this ability allows the pilot to
become invulnerable or invisible for two
seconds at a time by entering an
alternate dimension that's for pilots
but if you're an a ronin a sword
wielding Titan from titanfall 2 then you
have what's called phase - which is
basically the same thing except a
different name because you're in a Titan
one character very well known in the
series is a similar pilot named ash she
was formerly part of the apex predators
run by kuben BLISK who is the guy in the
beginning of the trailer the very old
man who actually runs the apex games and
she was also part of a bunch of other
military divisions but she ended up
dying by Jack Cooper in titanfall - but
then was picked up scavenged and
repaired by Vincent Dynamics she also
had the phase - on her Ronin Titan but
here's the weird part phase shift is
dangerous which is why the Malkin's can
only
use it because they're expendable robots
keeping a pilot in an alternate
dimension could have some weird effects
which is what I think this is now I did
state before that pilots did use the
phase shift but small currents can also
be considered pilots as well because you
can actually play as some of the robots
in titanfall too you don't actually have
to play as a standard human pilot pilot
is more of a general term for someone
who has the accessibility to wield a
Titan so that doesn't matter if they're
human or robot it is more of a general
term so just keep that in mind but as I
said phase shift can be pretty dangerous
for humans now the IMC has never stated
about using phase shift on pilots of
human descent because of the mysterious
effects that could take place thus
meaning only the robots can wield them
like I stated but the IMC doctors and
the scientists probably got pretty
curious about what those effects were if
there were even a need to begin with
since that is usually how science works
but they didn't want to sacrifice one of
their soldiers lives so they went to one
of the holding facilities like where
Wraith was held because like I said
previously she woke up in a detention
facility which is basically another
fancy name for jail or prison but seeing
as she was mentally ill they thought it
probably wouldn't be too big of an issue
if she died during the experiment
process because once she is in a soldier
fighting in the war and she's mentally
ill so she probably really can't help
them in terms of crop growing or
anything
technological to help them win the war
this may or may not be contributed to
the fact that Wraith might have
schizophrenia see schizophrenia is a
mental disease but with many different
subtypes but the most common one is
hearing random voices in your head
well everyone can technically hear
voices in their head there is
technically been a way more enhanced if
you read a sentence on your phone your
computer anywhere that little voice are
reading out the sentence for you in your
head that is basically your voice and
that's pretty normal for people but
schizophrenia is a whole different type
of ballgame there and seeing as she was
held in a facility for the mentally ill
it makes probably the most sensing as
she can hear voices and that is a sign
of schizophrenia which is also a mental
illness and she is mentally ill so I'm
pretty sure those to coincide together
and pretty much fit the puzzle there is
no description within the game stating
how Wraith got schizophrenia or these
voices in her head whether she was born
with it or somehow got it I'm actually
not even sure if that even exists in
real life in terms of are you born with
it or something like that so definitely
let me know in the comments below about
that but I'm just going to go off on a
limb and say that these voices are just
in her head and it's not some weird
godly spirit trying to prey on her and
unleash havoc which i think is a bit
outrageous and like I said before the
biography also talks about
search facilities hidden under the apex
game so there's actually no telling what
that is either I really wish that we can
discover these maybe later within the
games lifecycle maybe in later in year 1
or in year 2 maybe we can get access to
more areas in the map and we can go into
these facilities and then we can learn a
little bit more about what was taking
place in there so let me know what you
guys think about this in the comments
below just a quick recap I do believe
that Wraith was a mentally ill patient
at a detention facility who was then
brainwashed and erased of all of her
memories so that she probably couldn't
tie this back to the IMC and seeing how
is the test subject she probably didn't
consent to all this so this could
probably lead to some pretty bad things
on the IMC side and she probably got the
ability to summon the void and her
hearing of these voices probably got
more enhanced because of this experiment
taking place within the within the
facility to determine the side effects
of phase shift and alternating
dimensions seeing as they didn't want to
sacrifice any soldiers or any other
pilots trying to do this experiment
since those eight in the war so they
took some type of mentally ill patient
to see what the side effects were yeah
like I said if you guys have any other
ideas you want to contradict my theory
if you have a completely different
theory I'll definitely definitely leave
it in the comments below I'll be sure to
check it out I like to read the comments
especially about these theory videos
since like I stated numerous times
across these lore videos none of this is
really there in terms of info most of
this is just speculation like about 90%
of this script is about speculation
other than the fact that she woke up in
a detention facility because they really
don't give us anything regarding her
character whatsoever hey guys this could
be the end of the vid say hopefully guys
did enjoy I did get a new mic so
hopefully the quality sounds a little
bit better if you can even tell if
there's even a difference in quality if
there's not that's completely fine by me
I'm totally satisfied with my new audio
technica mic so let me know about that
in the comments below and as well thank
you guys so much for the love and
support on the octane video that video
is easily one of my most popular videos
and it within a week it's at like 420
thousand views so it's crazy stuff I'll
definitely be sure to cover the future
characters since you guys seem to love
those a lot but what that like to be if
you do enjoy subscriber for new my two
most recent apex lore videos are gonna
be popping up on screen a bit if you
guys want to check those out with that
and peace out have a great day
[Music]
you
[Music]